i can't teach anything divisive i can't
teach critical race theory
and i can't teach about racial equity
this is a call to action teachers we got
to stand up and fight for our kids
because this is [ __ ]
here's my call to action fire that
teacher
the teachers are not happy teachers all
over the country are not happy right now
forget about ron desantis for a second
they're not happy
that the right is calling out critical
race theory
there was one teacher just went viral on
tick-tock
who expressed her anti-racist
fury that that conservatives and parents
are finally asserting their rights over
their kids education this is what's
[ __ ]
today is the first time our country has
recognized juneteenth
it's national holiday and yet i'm
getting ready to go back to school in
the fall
and my governor has put into place some
ridiculous
legislation that many governors across
the country put into place such as i
can't teach anything divisive
i can't teach critical race theory and i
can't teach
about racial equity this isn't all
public
schools colleges and universities
so teachers in the past we've been
activists
after this show of last year we really
need to stand up and do what's right for
our kids right now so
this is a call to action teachers we got
to stand up and fight for our kids
because this is [ __ ]
we can't lie to them here's my call to
action
fire that teacher that teacher should
lose her job
but michael academic freedom
academic freedom does not mean what you
think it means
i'm a proponent of academic freedom in
the sense that
i believe scholars ought to be able to
study what they want to study
but i'm an opponent of academic freedom
if
if what that means is teachers are
allowed to teach whatever they want
they're not that's not their job
teachers are required that
the the job description of a teacher is
to teach the curriculum
it's to teach what the school has
decided ought to be taught to the
students
and who who decides then what ought to
be taught well
it's the parents have some say i think
the trustees have some say if it's a
public school
the people have some say the teachers
have some say in the way it's taught
and school administrators do as well but
it's not just
the case that these radical leftists
have the right to indoctrinate our
students in insane theories
and insane ideologies such as critical
race theory
such as everything else that she's
describing
that woman has no right to do that that
woman has no right to her job
and if she is now calling for activism
and equity or these are all just code
words for radical leftism
i guess the activism she's talking about
is actually just a synonym for it
then she doesn't have a right to be in
the classroom
conservatives need to be willing to use
our political power also known as the
government
to go in and exercise our political
right
okay we need to be able to go in and
kick teachers like that out of the
classroom i would strongly recommend
a radical leftist teacher who is calling
for activism and who's calling
for the pushing of leftist ideology in
contravention of the law
to be fired that's a good idea hey i'm
glad you liked that clip we got a whole
show the title is using
government for good you can get that
whole show right here on youtube
or at apple podcast it's your google
play on the audio side
you can also order my new book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds and i want you
right now before you leave to let me
know what you think
of all those things any of those things
the book the audio podcast or this video
or just about the weather today what you
think about the weather leave a comment
right now on this video we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you